this video is sponsored by metal
hellsinger also before we go any further
for context i decided to show my first
attempt at getting through the demo and
then my last attempt at getting through
the demo about an hour and a half worth
of gameplay apart just because i thought
the progression was very cool so that's
what you're about to see
i'm very excited about this game
hello everyone we are playing the demo
for metal hellsingers right now um i
have
a couple of friends who worked on this
game i met some of the team over the
weekend and they were all wonderful and
very excited it's called metal
hellsinger made by the outsiders
published by fun com
demo is available right now if you want
to check it out this is sponsored
but it's one of those situations where
when they were like we sponsor you to
play the game and i'm like guys come
play it anyway
so yes you can
um i have not played the demo this is my
first time playing
it was playable at summer game fest
which was uh
if you didn't know jeff geely organized
like an in-person
sort of e3 thing that would be like e3
so that we could play certain games but
i intentionally avoided even looking at
the screen so that the first time i
played this it would be fresh um
if you don't know
i'm missing out it is a rhythm fps
uh including some
crazy cool talent from the metal world
um
[Music]
they call it a rhythm shooter game your
ability to shoot on beat will enhance
your gameplay experience the more in
sync you are with the rhythm the more
intense the music will become and the
more destruction
you will cause which sounds amazing i
don't know that i've ever played
anything like this
there's a leaderboard i know that people
have been trying to get to the top of
the leaderboard
metal artists include people such as
serge tankin from system of down matt he
from trivium alyssa white please from
arch enemy
bites from lamb of god
it's all very cool also troy's in it
because of course he is um so without
further ado i expect to be bad on my
first run
i don't know how long it is
but we'll try and climb that leaderboard
i'm very excited
calibrate brightness skull is barely
visible i do not see a skull
there you go
metal hellsinger is automatically
configured to provide the best beat
matching experience when using low
latency audio and video devices if
you're using a wireless headphones
[Music]
i think we're probably okay
but maybe i should have i don't know i
don't seem to have any latency on my pc
setup so
troy's in everything when we record
playwatch listen tomorrow um
i expect to have a lot of questions to
ask him about
summer gamefest i didn't even know he
was going to be in it
to soar try doing a dash quickly anguish
gates of the judge's roadblocks uh i may
have to move my webcam at some point too
certainly probably need to make it
smaller
but i'm not sure just yet when the best
where the best place to put it is going
to be
[Music]
this
i am that's troy baker
i can't escape him
very doom looking
it's like a storm coming from far far
away
i'm really excited
[Music]
[Music]
okay okay
that's gonna be your dash that order
makes you block jump fly a little bit
okay
all right
i'm learning
it would be
two three four no i think i'm doing that
wrong i'll get that
i think those i'm just offbeat
beated actions are graded good or
perfect
okay
oh they're also glowing on beat
oh that's cool
i wonder if uh this is breaking my brain
because i keep wanting to start at the
beginning of the beat because of djing
seems like i'm doing okay
[Music]
how can i not hit you
so
the double jump is cool blowing enemies
of vulnerable tap eon beat just a lot of
them
this is going to be super fun when it
ramps up
dude
it's kind of like a dark side of vibes
as well
we didn't need words
we understood each other without them
i guess it sounds like
love at first sight don't it
you see the whole universe has a rhythm
well it's
kind of my pulse
and when i'm with her we sort of
become one
her music is my music and my voice is
herpes
pretty
sorry i'm very in the zone
chat voice actor sounds like troy baker
it is troy baker
okay what does this do
okay
pure increases by doing actions i'll be
perfect give some moisture
[Music]
oh i missed it
this is very fun
it's really interesting how differently
i'm looking at it pick up the pulsating
fury boost where is that
like
it's it's just making me pay attention
to gameplay in such a different way
oh
this rules dude
okay
i assume i also have like a traditional
gun but maybe not
this is so dope dude
oh my
i think what's happening that i probably
need to learn
um
is that
i'm not
really aiming like for some reason
focusing on well i was way off feet
though
uh focusing on hitting things on feet is
making me really inaccurate
um and i wonder why
bastards okay like my brain is like
separated those two things i don't know
oh thank you shadow kid
very very very cool so far
um
yeah the uh creative director is a
friend of mine
um
david goldfall but he's been so excited
about this for so long and again i met
some of the team at summer game fest
and they were i remember
just so cool and so excited and it was
like people really like your game and
they were like we know oh my god what's
happening really really like cool to see
people off their demos just release and
see their response to it okay
oh this is for me
okay
[Music]
[Music]
shotgun uses ammo auto reload oh do i
reload on beat two
this is so cool
yeah
i miss the
just by timing the e wrong it's probably
the one that i'm finding the hardest
because i think
my brain goes must press asap
[Music]
this is very unreal it's like nothing
i've ever played before
i feel like i will probably use the
shotgun most of the time right what is
this
nice
perfectly broke those pots you're damn
right
i didn't know i had an ultimate
buy the ultimate oh
okay
[Music]
wow that's sick
yeah my aim's terrible
there's a chaos crystal nearby troy
baker
that's how he
[Music]
sounds there are a lot of them here
[Applause]
i don't know where health is actually
maybe the green crystals in the
yeah it's okay we'll fit the first run
through figuring it out we'll get the
skull later it's fine
oh when things die i get health so you
just pick up the smaller guys
my aim's so bad
yeah i'm also not reloading
oh let's see what all for this is
that was cool
oh
[Music]
wait what
oh i converted somebody
this is so [ __ ] cool
like unbelievably cool
my god
i do want to try that the perfect reload
thing
oh it's awe okay
i hit mouse click for some stupid reason
that's sick too
got your active reloads
i keep
messing up the the e1 though we'll get
that we'll figure it out we'll learn
i don't want my meter to go down but i
do want to explore is the thing
which i wonder is like
maybe not a thing you do in this game at
all that's what i thought okay
[Applause]
this is also like entirely the music
that i listened to in high school it was
all this
[Music]
i wonder if the songs are on spotify yet
[Music]
oh it doubles me
i might go back to the shotgun i don't
know what i had i don't know it's on
it's on three
i need help
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is that everyone am i missing somebody
in here i should be looking for those
sooner two i reckon that's it's very
interesting how the music stops
like the sorry just the um singing
stopped because i wasn't uh
my combat multiplier as it were
wasn't high enough
[Music]
hmm
this this rules you can use this skull
and shoot at nothing to keep up with oh
interesting i don't know that i want to
cheese it that way but maybe when i'm
going for the
high score run i could do that i do like
the skull too um
though i oh you can change by a scroll
wheel i was gonna be like wish you could
change with the scroll wheel you can
i just so i recently uh had to come
clean with the internet
i've been saying for a long time that
deadly premonition is my favorite game
and i in fact
had to reckon with myself that that is a
lie
it is doom 1993
um and combining that with a rhythm game
like obviously it has dupe style we'll
do 2016 but
uh i keep messing the e up it's gotta
just overtake my brain
um
and music that i love is just
the coolest
did i miss anyone back there i don't
know i don't think so
i love that they're also doing all this
like fire flame effects that are just
like clearly
it does keep it up oh it just builds it
up yeah i'm not gonna we're not gonna do
that this time around when i'm going for
high schools we will um
they've really made it like metallica
concert type thing like music is more
metal than either doom 16 or a turn on
with the vocals i agree
but i also don't know that that's like
what mick gordon was going for
ah thank you moji mola as we call you
i already want this on spotify are these
songs that exist
because uh
generally is not how video game scores
work
not something like this like where you
would it would have to be so just
layered really specifically
i keep forgetting to do the reload as
well it's okay the first round we're
allowed
[Music]
that's dead
[Music]
[Music]
head streak goes up when you hit enemies
on i know
the game grants points for shifting to
tempo as well shifting the beat might be
your best chance of keeping combo while
exploring oh good to know
again gonna take it slow this time
regardless i think
just just learn and then we'll try and
uh improve as we go
uh
[Music]
[Music]
meet little guys
hold us
oh missed it
[Applause]
i feel like i'm also pressing my
keyboard and mouse really hard because
i'm like
god damn this is this is so so so cool
okay
oh i didn't even realize that the
reticle is like doing like a ddr type
thing
telling me
kind of
exactly what beat i'm hitting things at
you you're just a bunch of sticks and
some pulse i don't know that used to
have much of a chance
how did i lose
keep forgetting to do it
all right rise condemn souls come at me
is this a different bpm it feels faster
[Applause]
i feel like i probably have some of the
worst gamer face playing this i'm like
so
in the zone
[Applause]
where'd she go where you at
i wish to have that kind of confidence
in life god damn i have no weaknesses
this thing does not do a lot of damage
but i do like it for how much she moves
i wonder if it would do more if i got
closer it doesn't look like it
oh
[Applause]
oh that's a lot more damage
getting a reload
curious if the full game will be at one
tempo like one bpm that's what i was
saying it's like i'm not sure if it's
all at one bpm or not at this stage
um
because that is it's harder than you
think um
like
humans do have a lot of trouble with
shifts in bpm unless they're blended
which would ruin
the flow of the game
i just wasn't even paying attention to
what i was looking at there that's on me
this is so cool oh my camera move
i didn't even see that happening it
probably was the headbanging that's my
bad
there we go sometimes you just get into
a video game you know sometimes it just
happens
yes i have been using dash a little bit
um i just haven't really felt the need
to too much
but it's definitely like one of those
games and i love
you know finding something like this
where i'm like i need to learn like i
need to get used to playing this
like um
to managing how the game works and it's
exact like
like press r here press e here
but i always just find that super
exciting i need my help
i think i'm out oh i should have gone to
get that
ages ago
she's getting there she's getting there
but i am all out of hell oh this one
over there
let's go for it
[Applause]
do
[Applause]
beautiful work
aspect defeated
this rules so hard what the hell
and that's when i feel like i'm still
like fumbling i bet if you
you as you get better at it it just
feels cooler and cooler also give me a
second i want to
check the camera see if my dog is uh
destroying anything or just sleeping fun
game to play as a dog owner
he is destroying something
hey buddy what do you got
he's allowed to have that he's allowed
to have that that's okay
um okay
oh rank 33 000 don't mind if i do all
right let's go let's do it again
here's persephone i reckon we'll see
lots more of her
[Applause]
stop hitting me the absolute jerks
i kind of want to start again like feel
like i should be able to get through
this whole area without being hit and i
just need to learn how to do that sorry
this is how i play video games and i
know that it is not the best to watch
but it is how i play video games
okay yeah let's uh we'll have a zoom
call david and we'll figure out
my part in the game thank you
it's very um what are you buying i
remember this place like it was
yesterday
is there anything else i can do for you
this is my uh my live audition it's
great
i think i could do a demon i can make it
i can make it happen my dad ever since i
started working in game development
just keeps asking me to make him
a
dragon
you need any australian dragons in that
god of war i'm like i'm sure we do dead
i can't imagine god of war not needing a
specifically australian dragon
[Music]
and every time he's like g'day mate
how's it going okay yeah well i'll find
the pot for you bud
foreign
[Music]
no
jack
i messed it up
[Music]
but that's what i'm saying i think i can
in some universe get through this whole
bit without being hit
at least i should be able to
ah yeah that's
so many souls here makes a kind of
electricity
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh this is so satisfying
i missed that should have really should
have taken that earlier
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
everybody's here everybody showed up
trying to get to the shotgun i think i
went right over it
[Music]
i keep patting myself with those i
really really gotta stop
but i'm like oh explody thing
[Music]
all right it's my nemesis it's time for
the my nemesis
[Music]
i hate him so much where are you pumping
a little [ __ ]
nobody loves you
oh we did it it wasn't so bad
out of my face lads
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah i am really using the fury's wrong
like i really gotta do it
ah
um
when i lose
combo not when plumber's already up
doesn't make sense
it's just a shot completely out of time
ah
waiting for the e
[Music]
just
love a game where anytime i mess up i
know it's my own fault and not the
game's fault you know
i'm like wow you really did that huh
like games where the camera is the thing
that screws you
i'd be so tough
to forgive
[Music]
oh
[Music]
high rise
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know
[Music]
ah
i got this back up
[Music]
my best boy
[Music]
you are a tanky [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
all right all right okay i see you i see
you being angry out here
i feel like we take the [ __ ] out of this
dude
that's how you make clean whack of a big
boy
all right my queen feminist icon this
woman
i am higher i did see that
this is a to the beat fps my friend leah
and it is awesome
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
you
rise condemned souls
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
i love this song particularly this is so
dope
wasted that
[Applause]
where'd you come from i think he does it
every time actually
[Applause]
she is definitely my biggest challenge
which makes sense but she's the one
where i lose the history like every time
[Music]
doing that
anybody else yell at themselves when
playing video games
[Music]
wow wow wow wow no no no no no no no
absolutely not absolutely not this is
not happening right now no no no no no
no okay
[Music]
not that that was i said i have a lot of
help
panicked i'm really panicked right now
it's not gonna go well for me
[Applause]
[ __ ] dude [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
just die
just die
come on oh thank god
oh
oh it got spicy
okay i think i'm better than i was
before and that's all i want from myself
i did not wake the dog up so that's a
win too
damage taken higher than last time
damage taken is higher i was at 50 000
last time i think
um
so we did that i guess
headshots is higher
55 i think lasting was 49 percent do we
break the 10k
yeah
sorry bud
so i'm sorry
real game hours
it has gotten better
every time
and that is a sign of good game design
that is a sign of intuitive
learning
which is awesome um
i
should stop
i don't want to to be clear i would like
to keep playing the video game
but i should stop because it's 11 30 and
i have work tomorrow and i still need to
watch capcom
but i do not want to stop
no i'm like i can hear myself bargaining
with myself in my own head about like i
could just one more it's only like 15
minutes no i should stop
i should stop